as you know my name is Conan O'Brien or
for any of you ladies who watch the
Eclipse today without protective glasses
hi I'm Ryan Gosling I want to come back
to my place before your vision clears up
that's fine with me
it didn't fry their ears I know okay
[Laughter]
thanks Andy for pointing that out
sure no problem you're a good friend
there's a crazy story after bespeaking
of the Eclipse after being advised
specifically not to look at the Sun
without protective glasses true story
president Trump stared at the eclipse
today without protective glasses
he did it yeah after they told him not
to so afterwards everyone started
advising him whatever you do don't
resign okay have you seen the pictures
of him looking up yeah I know without
anyone looking at it like yeah that's
what they're talking about yeah it's
just what a joy ah that eclipse did you
watch the Eclipse did you see the
Eclipse yeah I literally was like I love
my son when I got huh alright I gotta go
you know what's really half an eclipse
whatever I'm being an ass The Weather
Channel covered the Eclipse all day
today all day yeah when asked why a
spokesperson for the Weather Channel
said Jesus until the next hurricane this
is all we freakin got this is for them
this was the greatest thing that ever
happened this is like the Oscars yeah
yeah they're probably mad that any other
channel covered it - what all we've got
is we let us have this and the Today
Show's covering it
a new report came out I found that it
cost so much to protect president
Trump's entire family that the Secret
Service is going bankrupt that's true in
fact today the Secret Service asked
Trump if they could just skip Eric
experts are saying that President Trump
is already preparing for the 2020
election yeah
now some people some people think that's
overly optimistic but others say no
he'll probably be paroled by then a new
book is coming out about the women who
shaped Donald Trump including his mother
his grandmother and his three wives it's
a book yeah yeah the book is entitled
way to go ladies
[Applause]
you